Thank you.
All right.
We should be live.
Hey, guys.
Let me know if you're here.
If you can hear me, drop a comment.
We're going to go into this live as soon as I get someone up here.
Look alive.
Make sure there's sound.
I also need to record this.
And then I got another student who's trailblazing, guys.
Someone who just broke through.
I have to show you that Christmas and Thanksgiving is no excuse.
It's a good time, but it's no excuse to put the foot on the brakes.
I think we're good.
Let me just check the sound here and we can rock.
There we go.
All right.
We got someone.
It's 10 o'clock.
Let's go.
All right, guys.
So let me get Morgan in here because he's got stuff to share that you
guys can definitely relate to.
And as he's telling his story and, you know,
laying it out, you guys, please drop some comments.
If you have any questions, this is a good time to ask questions.
All right.
Let me go ahead and get Morgan in.
Morgan, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Yeah.
Awesome.
I'm using the mic this time.
Cause I got a couple of questions.
Cause I got actually a message from one of the people in the group saying
that the only thing that they didn't like is the,
the quality of the voice.
Cause I was just using the microphone on the, on the camera.
So I played in the actual mic.
So you guys, hopefully you can hear me in.
HD now.
I guess.
Cool. Morgan.
I appreciate you making the time to jump on.
So for those who don't know who Morgan is,
tell us a little bit about your background, where you came from.
And how do you find yourself here?
Yeah. So actually it's funny.
I, I went to the military to be a special operations.
Combatitive.
And I washed out on a medical injury.
Then I got lucky enough to get into the military.
And then I got into the military.
And then I got lucky enough to get stationed in Hawaii.
And even though I was in this wonderland, I,
I want it more for myself. I felt like this isn't enough.
I need to figure out what's next.
So I saw this guy walking around the barracks and he was always just
looking so dapper.
He had a dress shirt, dress pants, a tie, just looking real fresh.
So I ended up going to him and being like, Hey man, what are you,
what are you getting into?
What's your reason for dressing like this?
Cause all the rest of us are just young people clocking into work,
coming home and figuring out what we're going to do with the rest of our
day.
Long story short.
He introduced me into this world of entrepreneurship,
but he was operating in an MLM.
And once I got wind that it was something kind of fishy,
I did a bunch of research.
And in one of the breakdowns,
I found a link to rank and rent.
And then that's how I hopped on and I made my commitment right away to
start giving myself to this business model fully.
And that's exactly how I made my exit plan from the air force.
How much did you spend in the air force?
I spent four years active duty in the air force.
And then I just cut ties.
I've never been a big fan of authority,
but you have to learn to follow before you can learn to lead.
Good point.
So you did that.
And then you,
you discovered MLM and it was kind of up your alley,
but not so much not.
You wanted something that's MLM,
but better than MLM,
like a little bit more upside and you found rank and rent and you're like,
Oh, this is better than multi-level marketing.
What drew you specifically to it?
Like when you watch these Nick videos, like what, what was it,
what was about it?
So to answer your first question as well,
I just didn't want to build my success off of other people's failure.
And that really is what MLM comes down to.
There is a very,
very small percentage of successful people in that.
So all the people you're bringing on likely will fail.
And what attracted me to the rank and rent model and to,
to Nick, I got into the rank and rent model before Nick,
but whenever I was introduced to Nick,
I took it from two to 3000 all the way up to 13 was my highest month that I
saw.
And it was just helping people, man,
helping people put bread on their table. And then I get it.
I get a slice of that bread, you know, for me, it's always been, if I,
if I'm not building my riches off of helping others to some capacity,
if I can't at least tell myself that not everyone else has to feel the same,
but if I at least can't tell myself that then I'm doing something wrong.
I like it. Yeah.
The, I heard this just the other day.
The right thing to do is always the right thing to do.
Yeah. And when it feels right, like, yeah, no, yeah.
When you've got, we talked about gut too, like that gut feeling.
When you don't feel it. I mean, you had this high, I mean,
the force or the air force is as high and persistent as it gets,
but still you found yourself in there, but it didn't click with you.
It didn't jive with you. So you wanted something better,
even though everyone that's in the air force was probably like, yeah,
this is it. This is, you know, as good as it gets, you know,
but you were still, you know, striving. Now, tell me about the two to three K.
What year was that as opposed to the 13 K per month, which is your peak,
right? Maximum that you got is 13. Okay. So what, what years were those?
So two to three K,
I want to say that was about a year and a half, two years in.
And what is that like 2022?
Oh, no, no, no.
It was either 2020 or 2021.
And I'm sure we'll get to it a little bit later,
but I had a lot of shiny object syndrome in my time.
So, yeah, I want to say it was about one in 2020, 2021.
It was right around beginning of COVID time where I started to really draw
in some money from that and then started to develop my exit plan.
As I started to count some of my eggs before they hatched,
because I just knew that staying under that umbrella of authority wasn't what
I wanted to do.
And I believe that you can be under an umbrella of authority and still find
freedom. But for me, it just wasn't happening.
Yeah. Yeah. It's just, that's your character. That's who you are.
Yeah. And I like also that you phased out.
I did the same thing. I had a full-time job. And then when I started this,
I went into part-time and hired someone and then switched,
trained them to do what I do, gave them the full-time, took the part-time.
And then three months later, I just phased out until instead of just pulling the
plug and going full board, that's a little scary.
Easing into it is the way to go.
And a lot of students are actually doing that in the group.
They have full-time jobs, full-time parents, bad asses,
and they also carve out time to go work on this, the rank and rent.
That way they're easing off of the work.
They're phasing out and then going full-time into rank and rent.
Yeah, I like it.
13K, obviously got some shiny objects in your way, some rabbit holes.
We all do. I still do.
I just got two companies yesterday reaching out to me to build big websites.
So that's going to be a rabbit hole.
So it's my focus now to make sure that my team is self-sufficient.
I don't have to touch those websites. I don't have to think about them or anything.
So yeah, it is an ongoing thing.
And if you think that you've passed it, you are mistaken.
It's going to come again and again and again.
Because the more you gain experience, the more people put you on a pedestal,
the more you deliver to people, the more they believe in you and they give you other things.
Like, oh, you're great at rank and rent.
Can you do my social? Can you do this?
And you start throwing things at you.
I mean, it's your job, sure, to take care of those people, make that green, make that money,
but without sacrificing your time and your focus for rank and rent.
Because that's what happened.
I get pulled into a project and then I wake up like three months later.
Like, what happened?
I made some money with that website and SEO, but there goes three months.
I didn't touch any rank and rent in three months.
So what was your situation, Morgan?
How did you get distracted?
So actually, right away, I don't know why I felt like I needed someone to be there by my side.
You know, who knows?
Who knows?
In my younger years, maybe I was subconsciously lonely.
Maybe I just wanted someone to be big with.
But when I left the military, I called up one of my buddies and he was making money.
He was making money.
Go ahead.
He was making money in a not so enriching way, but had a lot of entrepreneurial experience.
So I asked him if he wanted to come on as a partner.
Obviously, he wouldn't get any of the profitability of what I've already accomplished.
But if he helps me to do these new sites and things like that.
So we gave it a shot for a while and he made a little bit of money, but it really didn't work.
And then we separated and we made what's called state of mind labs.
And we were doing hemp, just basically hemp wholesale to various countries,
mostly Japan, Australia, Denmark, Ireland, a lot of different areas like that.
Like for fabric and rope and stuff?
Distillates and isolates.
So actually compounds that they could consume.
And I stayed on top of my marketing as well and got up to 13K, had a lot of 10K, 11K, 12K months.
And then state of mind labs started to show this potential of making lots and lots of money.
So little by little, more and more of my attention started to shift.
And at that point in time, I still didn't have a full time team around me like I do now.
So it was a lot of work that just wasn't getting done the way it used to.
And then after state of mind labs, I created another company called Ion Solar.
And this was to do with me creating customer flow.
And then I had three other partners and their jobs were manufacturing equipment
and creating that culture for the sales reps to go out and close these deals.
Great concept, but I took a lot of people on that had no experience whatsoever.
And they were really in that blue collar, nine to five mindset.
So it was really hard to keep accountability for everyone.
That was one that didn't last long, but took a lot of my funds.
And then I saw my marketing company coming down from those big numbers
and hitting lows as low as $3,500 per month.
And my savings were just getting eaten into.
So we closed down Ion Solar.
And then we opened up another company called Shenzhen Sales Ventures.
And we opened this one up because we saw that state of mind labs was dying.
The wholesale industry was getting too competitive
because manufacturers were figuring out how to get that same visibility
that the brokers like ourselves were getting.
So we weren't really able to middleman as efficiently.
So we were like, okay, well, now we know how to build a sales organization.
So let's go into the retail space and we can just broker for all these other companies.
We did that for a while, but we found out that even though we were running up the commissions
super high for our people and they would just be making aggressively good money,
whenever you don't pay that base salary, you really can't hold them accountable either.
So it just became a lot of accountability.
And I just couldn't figure out how to hold all these other people accountable
in these other business models.
So then I came back.
I told my partner, I said, hey, look, I don't want a partnership with this.
I took a lot of the heavy load.
So I want you to get me back this much, but the company's yours.
Keep it.
And I'm shutting down all the other ones except for my marketing company.
I'm going to go back to my roots.
So that was about two years, two years of being completely off track
from when I had hit 13K and then I had to start building back up.
I had a couple of $3,000 a month, $3,500 a month, which just was not cutting it,
not when that is your primary source of income.
So what I did was I moved back home to get a big reset.
And it's been the best thing I possibly could have done.
I've been away from family for seven years.
I come back and I'm enriching those relationships again.
I got back up to $10,000 a month during these holidays.
October was my $10,000 month.
These holidays, November, December, $7,500.
But I'm actually pretty happy with that because I didn't lose any clientele.
Some websites during the holidays will still get leads and some will get zero.
Absolutely nothing.
And just me in the goodness of my heart,
I know everyone runs their rank and rent a little bit different,
but I can't charge someone during the holidays
and not have them put gifts on their family's table.
That's just not in me.
And I know other people aren't always the same and I don't judge those people.
Everyone has the right to make their own decisions in this life.
But now I came to the conclusion that I have no interest
in building any partnerships with anyone
because in this business model, you really don't need anyone.
You don't need anyone else except for yourself.
And as far as the shiny object syndrome,
I've got a lot of other business models with low-hanging fruit
that I'm just pushing off, but there is one thing I am working on.
And what's so cool about it is it plays directly into what I'm already doing,
which is SEO.
And that is targeting luxury real estate in certain areas of the country
so that all I have to do,
I don't have to go out and hunt for my own people to sell their homes
or to go and find them to buy homes.
And it's in a luxury market,
so the dollar is going to go a lot further for those commissions.
But every day I can just wake up, work on my marketing,
have my secretary handle all of my customer flow for my real estate stuff.
And if I have to go do a meeting, okay,
put my team to work for the day, make sure everything's going smoothly.
And that's it, man.
That's my vision for the future.
I feel like I just didn't know how to manage in the past.
And you always think you can do more than you can in the short term,
and you always underestimate what you can get done in the long term.
And those are wise words, man.
I definitely agree with you,
but I also want to commend you for being entrepreneur ballsy, okay?
Because not everyone can just get up and say,
hey, I'm going to start a solar company.
And you look like you're in your early 20s, right?
Mid-20s?
27.
I mean, yeah, mid-20s.
I mean, that's the age where you need to be ballsy and go all out
and try different things, absolutely.
But in your advantage, you matured early, you made mistakes early,
and you found yourself back.
There's nothing wrong with being entrepreneurial,
but it's like a later step.
It's like a phase three or phase four after you've mastered this,
after you've built your cash, after you've built your assets.
You're like, okay, everything looks good.
Time to jump into, take this cash and go invest it somewhere else.
Yeah, I mean, your head is in the right direction.
I think you were just a little early.
I was early.
I shouldn't have jumped.
Too much too early, right?
Too much too early.
You're so right, man.
And a lot of people say don't do business with family,
but I always thought if you can't trust family, then who can you trust?
Or friends, if you can't trust friends, then who can you trust?
But at the same time, one thing I had to learn was
you can't just turn these people into what you want them to be.
They already have to be those people.
And yeah, if I wouldn't have jumped ship so early,
I'm sure I would have had a lot more patience.
And I was always looking for different opportunities,
but I should have mastered this model first.
And now that's exactly what I'm doing.
So 13K, that's going to be blown out of the water in 2025.
I have a minimal standard of 15,
and I'm really aiming up for 20 before the end of this year.
And then obviously with the real estate stuff on the side,
that'll add in some fat paydays as well.
So we're on the right track now, 100%.
But yeah, definitely jumped ship a little too early.
If you think that it's the right time,
weigh out the pros and cons because I was just excited, man.
And that excitement can bite you in the butt sometimes.
I almost jumped into swag.
I almost started selling swag.
Actually, Nick did. Nick jumped on it, and I didn't.
And I remember him just being like, wow, that was dumb.
This was before the program, by the way.
Yeah, we made mistakes too.
Nick got into swag.
He would make promotional items, and there's a site,
and you order them, and they go straight to the customer.
I was about to jump on it, and then he was complaining.
I was like, you know what?
I'm going to go back and get out of this rabbit hole
and go back to my track.
So yeah, we've all been there.
We've all went into those rabbit holes
and came back with more wisdom and more maturity.
Like, oh, it doesn't have to be complicated.
It doesn't have to be big.
It doesn't have to be elaborate.
Simple and stupid sometimes pays the bills.
Sometimes we get too smart for our own good.
Like, oh, this is easy.
I could definitely fit some more stuff.
Let me go look, see what else I can do.
No, no, no.
Just take the same wheel that's turning
and just spin it faster and faster and faster.
And then once it starts to wobble, add another wheel,
turn that faster, and then you keep adding those wheels
instead of going and finding other stuff.
There's something in a book that I read,
and the book is called The Way of the Superior Man,
and this can apply to women as well,
maybe not the whole entirety of the book,
but the concept is living on your edge, right?
And when you live on your edge,
you want to be right over your edge, right?
Because if you go too far over your edge,
you're going to be spread too thin.
And if you're not on your edge at all,
you're in the level of comfort.
You're in the zone of comfort,
and you're not going to grow at all.
So just pushing yourself just right over that edge,
where it's a little uncomfortable, but it's manageable,
and you can flow, and you can just find your rhythm.
That's where you want to be.
Yep, absolutely.
And putting people in the right place.
I think that's instrumental too,
because you can stick to one...
You have a really good point.
Yeah, you stick to one thing,
but then as you rinse into repeating,
you hit capacity at one point.
And it's like you're going 120 miles an hour,
and then once you hit 140 miles an hour,
your steering wheel starts to shake.
And that's when you're like,
oh, okay, I need to hire someone.
I'm going to start offloading.
That's your sign to start offloading.
And you mentioned something important earlier,
where you delegate the things that you've already mastered.
And Nick has hammered on this point before.
Like in your case, you've got a secretary,
and anything that doesn't have value,
like a task that doesn't have a lot of value,
you pass it on, and you just keep the high-value tasks.
And then even those high-value tasks,
once you master them, you get an expert to push those on.
Like I stopped building websites,
I stopped doing social, I stopped doing all the technical stuff.
I used to do all of it, and it sucked,
because I was my own bottleneck.
The work was slow because of me.
The minute I got an expert in each thing,
content manager, web developer,
they're doing a much better job than I did.
And now the wheels are turning faster and faster.
So yes, sometimes we are our own bottlenecks.
And that could be another thing to touch on too,
is you have to know when it is the right time
to start delegating that work,
because I have always been such an excitable person,
and I feel like now I can be a lot more serious,
and I can weigh out pros and cons a lot more efficiently
because of all those failures
that have allowed me to be more successful.
That was another one I did.
I hired too much too early on,
and now I feel I found that perfect balance
that allows me to grow,
that allows me to just spread everything out
in a more strategic manner while still keeping me busy,
because there were times where I hired too much,
and it's like, all right, what am I even supposed
to be doing right now?
You know, so that's definitely another thing to consider.
Nice. Tell me about this team.
How did you hire the first member of your team?
The first member of my team was just all-inclusive SEO,
and I felt like my on-page was really strong,
but my off-page is what I always wanted to master.
I feel like off-page is harder for most people.
So I hired someone that was really good off-page,
and she manages everything as far as backlinking,
contact, outreach.
She manages our content writers and our blog strategies
and our interlinking.
So she started with just off-page,
and then she evolved into doing a lot of other things
as well, interlinking.
Project manager, then. It's kind of a project manager.
Yeah, for sure.
She's really evolved into her role,
and she's definitely the most independent
of all of my people.
So sometimes she's a little harder to get through
than the others, but that's kind of what you need, right?
If you're going to look for a leader,
you need someone who's going to be a little more independent,
who's going to be able to take things into their own hand
and to just move forward.
One of my greatest additions, however, I feel,
was my Google Business Profile Manager.
She is an absolute rock star.
I don't understand how she gets as much done
as she does in time.
I use Hubstaff, and she's busy 90% of the time.
Her screen's just moving.
And she actually turned out to have some hidden talents
as well with graphic design.
So now she'll do designs for the website,
even though she's only ever done graphic designs
for different posters and different posts
and content for social media.
But it turns out she has a knack for web design as well.
So she's been an amazing addition.
I do keep content writers on hand for off-page SEO
and for our on-page strategies as well.
And I had a web developer, man, but you know what?
I kind of like it.
I kind of enjoy it.
I can cut on a podcast,
something that's interesting to me.
And I can just develop my websites.
I kind of got a little spoiled to that.
I'm sure there will come a point
where I become too busy to do that.
But right now, that's all I do is sales and development.
And everything else is outsourced.
Sales and development.
I see you outsourcing the development
and keeping the sales.
Once your sales becomes overwhelming,
yeah, I see you definitely passing the development over.
I do too.
I had tried it, but I didn't like it.
I have had, that is such a hard thing to find,
is a good developer.
I can't tell you how many developers I've collaborated with
since I've gotten into this business model,
and I might have had one out of 10 good experiences.
Really, I've had amazing developers.
Hit me up, I'll help you.
I'll find you a rock star.
Yeah, I've been especially lucky with web developers.
Sales, not so much.
I've failed so many times in finding salespeople.
Commission only.
I mean, yeah, you can find the base pay everywhere.
They just get paid and do office work.
But I wanted a closer that can just work off commission
and just hit them like whack-a-mole, right?
I did not find them.
I hired and fired and hired and fired.
But the web developers, I can hook you up.
That's easy.
I actually got them from online, jobs.ph.
That's the sign-up for them.
That's what I prefer as well.
Yeah, and the developers that I have are amazing.
Like you said, they have hidden talents.
So you get a developer and they already have a background in IT.
Heck yeah, IT.
I want someone who knows IT because we have server issues.
We have all kinds of stuff.
Yeah, I'll take IT all day.
They have SEO backgrounds.
I love that.
But you've got to set the parameters.
It's tricky because SEO is an ocean, right?
It's like the Pacific Ocean.
And the SEO that we do is like just the island of Hawaii.
We do a very specific type of SEO that is white hacks, not spamming.
You can do all kinds of SEO.
So it is important if you're bringing an SEO person to set parameters for them.
Here's a due diligence sheet.
Here's how we survey, how we do the find the low-hanging fruit.
Here's how we do this.
That way you narrow down what they're working with and they're not sabotaging your stuff.
Not intentionally, of course, but they might sabotage your stuff.
They might sabotage your stuff unintentionally by doing things that they think are right or white hat.
I like that.
Black hat's going to become extinct.
What's that?
Black hat will become extinct.
Yes.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah, all the platforms now in search engines have AI and they're cracking down hard.
It worked when I first got in.
And I know it worked for people even more before I got in.
But man, white hats, when there's Google updates now, I look forward to them because my site.
Yeah.
You're waiting for them to wash out.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's awesome, man.
So tell me about.
So right now you have this rock star person that's like organizing your life basically, which I find myself in the same same situation.
I have an amazing project manager, an amazing team, but especially an amazing project manager.
Because like you said, I don't have she's very intuitive.
She knows me.
She knows what decisions I'm going to make before I make them.
And she goes and makes them on my behalf.
She goes and answers emails and deals with customers and all that stuff.
So I'm free to do the business development before I struggled.
I did the dance.
You know, the prospect fulfill prospects fulfill.
And you're running around.
If you're fulfilling, you're not selling.
And once you're done with the fulfillment, you're like, oh, my gosh, back to sales.
My sales are dropping.
And then you go start selling, selling, selling, selling.
And then you're like, oh, I got a couple of accounts.
You go manage them.
And then you constantly back and forth instead of sticking with sales and whatever you're selling, you're throwing over to your team.
And you're still in sales.
You're focusing. You're not running back and forth between fulfillment and sales.
So, yeah, it took some time, but I think I'm 95% out of fulfillment.
I still have my hands a little dirty, but that's the plan because I'm realizing that that is what affects sales.
It's going and doing the fulfillment.
Now I am the face of the company.
That's who people buy from.
They buy from me, not from my company.
So I have to show my face.
I have to be looped in on the emails.
I have to do certain things.
But I'm working on removing myself because I'm not adding anything that's of value.
I sell and my team takes care of everything, and they do it better than I do.
So why would I be in the way?
Why would I, you know, jump in there?
I hear that.
My hands are definitely still a little bit dirtier than yours are as far as staying in the trenches and doing different things like that.
But that's OK with me.
You know, I took a lot of risks.
And now I kind of did have to pay for those risks a little bit, but a lot, actually.
But that's perfectly fine because you are who you become.
Like, that is your value.
And that's why you always see these people, right?
They go on YouTube and they're like, oh, billionaire starts with zero dollars.
How fast can you get up to that?
Right.
And it's because they are not their assets at that point.
They are the person they become and the abilities that they have within them.
So I'm OK being here right now because I do have that abundance of time as I make my move.
When I'm making my move at the beginning of the new year to go and to also take on the real estate stuff, then my hands will definitely be a little bit less dirty in the marketing realm.
And I'll be focused on sales for homes and sales for rank and rent.
And then I'll have my teams doing all support, filtering through all the nonsense that I don't need to be looking at.
And that'll be all I'll be worried about is just interacting with my clientele.
And that's what I love. I'm a big people's person.
I'm super extroverted.
If I see you and you interest me, you better run because I'm going to talk to you.
I like that.
And you're mixing physical real estate and there's a little real estate.
So you still still have the entrepreneurial bug, but at least it's manageable.
It's extremely manageable whenever you're not, you know, giving all of your attention to this and that.
You know, if you have a secretary to qualify your leads on the real estate side, I don't I don't foresee it being any sort of an issue.
The issue is always that I was trying to just hit grand slams all the time.
You know, so I do have a little bit of the bug, but I've actually seen a lot of people do this on a smaller scale and be successful with it.
I am trying to do it on a larger scale with the luxury.
But that also means less clientele to have to deal with.
You just go to a big metro city and you're targeting all these.
You're going to be running with your head cut off.
But you go and you sell some 20 million dollar homes.
Your commission is a year, year long salary.
So that's something I'm looking forward to because it's not going to be as time demanding as, say, your normal walk of the day.
Real estate agent.
Yep.
Tell me about the rest of the team.
So you've got this person who's organizing your your chaos.
What else is out there?
You said there's some projects, some content writers.
Yes, so I have.
I have a couple of content writers and one of them.
He only he'll do like enter pages if I need a new service page.
Hey, Tom wants to do wallpaper as well.
He said that there's a lot of hotels looking for wallpaper.
Let's get a service page out for that and let's target these keywords.
I've given them a lot to work with.
Like the new concept keyword cannibalization came out and that's something I had to educate them on.
Hey, for our blog stuff, we don't want to confuse search engines.
Let's do this.
And they learn very quickly.
Their ears are open to hear.
And I have another guy and he'll also help with the blog strategies.
But his main priority is any time we have blogs to be created for guest postings that he is immediately on that.
And it people are willing to work for cheaper nowadays of a man.
I prefer real content.
I know you can get away with a content for a lot of stuff.
And I did that for state of mind last for a while, but I prefer that real content.
I don't think that AI content is penalized right now.
I just think that it can sound really generic and it can be the same kind of stuff on repeat.
So I try to steer clear of that for for a lot of my stuff.
And I have I have another I have Joanne.
She's amazing as well.
She does the most detail.
If you want to rank for something on a blog, you give her the topic and you let her run with it.
Outbound links, inbound links, 2000 plus words.
She can write about anything and it's none of its filler content.
She's a superstar.
She's also got her real estate license in the Philippines.
So whenever that started up, she's going to be able to qualify people on a really intimate level to ensure that none of my time is wasted.
So, yeah, my team's been awesome and I couldn't do it without them.
They truly do give me the time to be that creative leader and to be that visionary and to continue to progress us forward.
I like it. So project manager, content managers, you're still doing the development.
Now, tell me, how are you going to weaponize this team for 2025?
What are you going to do that's different from from 2024?
I think I think I'm just going to make an addition as far as the development.
And what I really like to do now that we're actually starting to come into a flow is I would like to have more cohesiveness and more of a culture.
I know with whenever I had my sales organizations, we would always do these big group Zoom meetings and things like that.
And the key is to not overdo it. You know, you want your people to be at work as well.
But I think that's probably going to be that next step is going to be to get everyone on the same page together because I've been noticing like there's some information gaps here and there.
And it doesn't happen often. But when it does happen, you as a leader have to be like, how can I prevent this in the future?
And for me, that's that's really what I believe is going to do that.
And there will also be this person on the GBP side will be like, we need to target these the most.
And then this person on the SEO side will be like, we need to target these the most. And there's that there's that gap right now.
So that's probably going to be the main thing that I'll do is develop a more cohesive culture now that the team is growing and getting larger.
So there's like a better flow, like less clunk in the operation, better information flow.
And and everyone's the main priorities of the company overall will be a lot more clearly visible.
Yep. And you're trying to hit 15 K. Is that the goal for early early 2025?
15 K is the goal for the first couple of quarters of the year.
And I want to be well above 10 K sitting comfortably in the 10 K plus range in that first quarter of the new year.
I didn't know you had this kind of operation. I thought maybe you had one employee. But I mean, if you have these kind of resources.
Oh, yeah, it you just have to be really careful with the due diligence.
The way I do it is I do it with my SEO gal.
So I would do the due diligence, come up with the idea and then pass it to her.
And she does a deep dive. And then she tells me, oh, this is a yay.
This is a nay based on the parameters that I gave her, of course.
So I do like an initial due diligence and then she goes and actually pulls everything.
The Google Trends, the AHA Trust, the Google Analytics search volume, all that stuff.
And then she gives me the I tell her I need a low hanging fruit.
You can give me a big city where I can make bank, but I'm blowing a lot of money on Google.
I would rather get that smaller, way smaller city that has a really good low hanging fruit, but I can get organic free leaves.
So she's smart, man. I didn't I didn't always take that route.
I mean, you can go look up Dallas. I've got number one sites in Dallas.
I've got number one sites in Oahu, a lot of big areas.
But with that being said, I've been in this game for so long that even though I wasn't giving it the attention it deserved, I have so much referral work now.
And I have so much people that are paying me to power up these websites for them.
It's just it makes sense. It makes sense to do that sometimes.
I play the game. Don't get me wrong. I have a site in Seattle, Washington.
I have a website in Milwaukee, like some really big, big cities.
But I learned that it takes less time and effort to go to a smaller city or just a city over and break records.
Like everyone's like bunched up in that city trying to get every crumb of bread.
And if you just move over just 20 miles, you'll be taking everybody's lunch.
And yeah, that's that's what I'm doing now. Like I'm I'm trying to take it easy.
Don't go for I'm going for high niche, obscure city.
Before I used to go for obscure city. Sorry. Big city, obscure niche.
Now I'm flipping it. Just regular stuff that I do. Epoxy, whatever.
But I'm looking for that obscure city that everyone is asleep.
How many leads do you find you generate in your smaller cities and what kind of a population size could you give 100,000?
I don't like under 100,000. It needs to be 100,000.
But, you know, when you got like two million people, that's when you're going to find big competition.
So when you find, you know, two to four million, just move over to the suburbs and you'll you'll probably strike gold just in the suburbs,
which is also a back door to the big metropolitan area, the suburb itself.
Like you're still collecting leads from Chicago, but you're all the way in Naperville or Batavia or the west suburbs.
You're an hour away, but you're still pulling from Chicago. That's just an example, of course.
Yeah, but I like it, man. 15K is a great goal.
I think we should set up a time for like February to, you know, have a touch point and see where you're at.
This is a great goal. It's not too hefty.
And at the same time, it's because you're going to be doubling what you're making right now, right?
Seventy five, eight thousand a month. So you're going to have to double that.
When you double that, it's going to feel good. It's going to catapult you to the next phases.
I kind of I kind of feel more like I'm starting at 10 to after these holidays push past.
That's going to bounce right back up to that number.
But nonetheless, we're at 75 right now. So you're right.
We are going to be doubling it. But I that's my complete intention.
And we're going to make it happen in there. You've been there. Yeah.
Yeah, you've been there. You can do it again.
The my thing this year is to focus on the hooks.
And I mentioned this in other lives is if I can have four hooks a week constantly.
I just closed one yesterday. So now I have three hooks today.
I need to get a fourth hook because when you keep selling them or losing them.
Now you just have one hook to work with.
That's not enough because you might lose two clients that you closed five months ago
and now you lost two and you have one hook that might close and might not.
So having four hooks for me keeps my my my head space same.
And I'm not desperate. I'm in control.
And I have control over the situation, not the business owners and control of my fate.
I really like that. I have been in this business for over four years now.
My longest standing client, I want to say, is right around three and a half.
We're coming up on our four year mark. Nice. My shortest client a month.
Right. You just you never you never know how long it's going to be.
And obviously the better performing sites are going to hold it down a little bit better.
But some areas get more spam and that'll just it'll just make someone so mad that they'll just drop it at some point.
And what you do to try and get rid of that spam.
So, yeah, you're completely correct in saying that it's like this this game is like you can find some lifers, but not everyone's going to be a lifer.
Yep. Lifer is a good word. Yeah, absolutely, man.
So, yeah, when you keep the numbers high on your end, you don't get desperate.
You don't you don't get scared. Fear is a big thing.
And fear is smells, you know, these business owners are like tarantulas.
They can smell, you know, how a tarantula can like smell fear or whatever and bite you if you're freaking out.
I didn't know that. Yeah, they like they smell that.
What's the hormone for fear or excitement dopamine?
Skydivers. What do they get? They get that rush. Adrenaline.
Adrenaline. Thank you. Yeah.
Apparently, tarantulas that smell adrenaline. Yeah, guys, Google it.
And I may be, you know, talking about it, but I heard it.
So, yeah, business owners, they smell that, too.
And they see that you're like, oh, my God, I'm freaking out.
It's Christmas and I don't have any more hooks. This is the only hook I have.
I have to close it. I have I have to tell them everything and it just oozes out of you.
And they're like, oh, yeah, no, thanks.
But when you have four hooks, you look comfortable.
You kick back. You're like, yeah, this is my price. This is how it works.
I thought you were interested in business. I thought you wanted to grow your business.
And now you're throwing all this stuff at me and you don't want to move forward.
What's going on? And you're very calm and you're very collected and you're argumentative.
You're bringing solid arguments. They can't they can't compete with that.
So they buy. Yeah. You get emotional or you get scared.
You lost the deal. That's right. Absolutely.
Well, I appreciate you jumping on. This is really valuable, man.
I took some notes and I'm definitely going to use some of the stuff that you talked about.
I like the way you're structuring your team.
I think that's going to be the biggest tool weaponize your team to the max
because and give them as much as you can.
I always say you don't need a meeting. You just need a screencast, like just record.
Every time they ask you a question, record a video for them and send it to them.
That's what I do. And it has been so instrumental because by the time we get to the touch point,
the weekly touch point, I've already sent them two videos.
They know what I want. They already elaborated on what I want.
They gave me even more better ideas.
And yeah, every time you want to communicate with your team, send them screen recording because those stick.
And if that question pops up again, here's that link. I answered it before. Here you go.
And we can compile that into training. You can do so much with it.
So, yeah, keep your communications through video because it's super, super instrumental.
Sweet. Anything else? Let me see. There's no questions.
So I hope they brought up some questions later. They're probably just Christmas shopping.
Frantically Christmas shopping because it's the 18th. I hope you guys are done.
But Morgan, I appreciate you, my man. Thank you for sharing your time and these awesome nuggets today.
And I will see you in the group. Yeah, thank you. I appreciate it. All right. See you guys.